Imagine I have a
beautiful tree that's filled with
oranges and I asked myself
What is the orange made of how do I answer that question? Well, I want to look deeply inside the orange. So I
Magnify it and I magnify it again and if I keep on doing it deep inside
sooner or later I begin to see molecules come into view but molecules are not the end of the story because the molecules I
can enlarge
them and if I make them big enough deep inside, I begin to see
Atoms atoms are not the end of the story too because we have electrons
Zooming around the nucleus deep inside mostly empty space in the atom, but deep inside
We see the nucleus. So if I grab that and magnify it
I see that the nucleus is itself made of particles neutrons and protons
and if I grab one of the neutrons and magnify it
I find yet further particles little tiny quarks inside
Now that is where the conventional idea stopped
String theory comes along and suggests that inside these particles there is something else
So if I take a little quark and I magnify it
conventional idea says there's nothing inside but string theory says I'll find a little
tiny filament a little filament of energy a little string like filament and just like the string on a
Violin, I pluck it and it vibrates
Creates a little musical note that I can hear the little strings in string theory when they vibrate
They don't produce musical notes. They produce the particles themselves
so what quark is nothing but a string vibrating in one pattern an electron is nothing but a
string vibrating in a different pattern a neutrino
Nothing but a string vibrating and different patterns still so if I take all of this back together
I have my ordinary orange and if these ideas are right, they are speculative
But if they are right deep inside the orange or any other piece of matter
There's nothing but a dancing vibrating cosmic symphony of strings
That's the basic idea of string theory